hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
yesterday Amazon released their fire
phone and basically every major tech
publication wrote something about it
it's that sort of an all-time high in
terms of curiosity right now and I
didn't expect to see so many people
interested in it but I've gotten a lot
of questions about it so the fire phone
is a new smartphone with a custom OS
from Amazon fire OS it's built on top of
Android and it's based around a couple
of pretty unique features the number one
of these being what's called dynamic
perspective and that they just sent an
email to a lot of people you're
interested today saying that this is the
first smartphone with dynamic
perspective it's kind of like 3d but not
really so the phone has four
front-facing cameras one on each corner
to track your face and uses a tracking
with an accelerometer and gyroscope to
shift what's on the screen a bit to make
it feel more immersive it works with
their new custom user interface it works
with a few apps here and there when you
tilt works with a few games here and
there you can use it to scroll down
lists and pages without touching a
display yeah this isn't it this is
really new when I turn it it moves whoa
The Verge actually did a great hands-on
video with the phone and I'll have that
linked right below the like button if
you want to check this out in action too
a lot of people this will either scream
awesome or gimmick depending on who you
are but either way you look at it this
is the main headlining feature of this
phone the second major feature is what's
called Firefly and it has its own button
on the side of the phone when you press
it it opens up Firefly and just start
scanning with the camera and the
microphones and whatever you point the
phone at it will recognize it so if you
have a TV playing a show in the
background or if you have music playing
in the background or if you point it at
an object it will scan that and
recognize it and then bring up a link to
buy it on Amazon of course Amazon is
hoping you'll really like this feature
and start taking major advantage of it
and buying lots of things on Amazon
based on what you recognize around you
pretty self-explanatory this is supposed
to make Amazon more money but besides
those two major new headlining features
there is just a couple of other things
sprinkled in
you have your Mayday live tech support
so the same thing I was on the Kindle
Fire tablets you now get that live quick
tech support on
phone and since it's the fire OS made
specifically for this phone you have a
couple of other features like a
notification tray live weather updates
some gesture stuff they have quick
settings it's made to compete and it's
got these new features to stay with that
you also get a free year of Amazon Prime
but here's the thing about the fire
phone it costs six hundred and fifty
dollars off contract and that brings up
a lot of questions about what exactly
you're paying for here and to be honest
basically all of the songs features
except for dynamic perspective and I
guess Mayday could be packaged into an
app one app a five or $10 Amazon fire
app that could look at what the camera
is looking at and interpret it and give
you an Amazon like to buy it we actually
already kind of had versions of that
you've probably already heard of Shazam
and SoundHound where you can just listen
to whatever music is playing it'll give
you a link to buy that song on iTunes or
Amazon or whatever and then at one point
we had what's called Google Goggles
which you've probably already heard of
which let you just point your phone at
anything it would recognize it and then
give you a Google Shopping link to buy
whatever you were getting it didn't know
his work it wasn't perfect but it did
basically the same thing and at one
point Google now even had that command
built into it so Amazon could have built
a Amazon fire or Firefly app and just
package that and sold it on Android and
iOS stores and called it a day but
because they decided to make a phone out
of this and not just an app now they
have to make all these things for the
phone they have to make the custom fire
OS for the phone sized screen now they
have to make all these custom apps
because they don't have access to the
Google Play Store or the iOS App Store
and for third-party apps they're still
going to depend on Amazon's App Store
because again they can't use a Google
Play Store or the iOS App Store and they
have to do manufacturing and production
and packaging and Amazon's never made a
phone before so this is their first try
at all of that I'm not doubting them I'm
not saying they can't do it but this is
a lot of work to do for these features
you want to sell people and they also
have to work with a carrier to sell this
phone and they only worked with AT&T so
it's exclusive to AT&T at this point and
it's $650 off contract so they made a
$650 phone instead of an app or two I
mean I guess on one hand that's that's
kind of ballsy and confident about what
they have to offer but
on the other hand that seems pretty
silly not everyone has to make a phone
remember when Facebook decided we have
to make a phone and the HTC first was
born how long did that last really so
I'd be surprised if we saw this Amazon
fire phone lasts as long as that I mean
I'd be I'd be surprised if we saw a
version two of it next year even for 200
bucks Amazon's Kindle Fire tablet makes
more sense because you actually get a
unique new form factor specifically for
reading you know it actually has some
advantages over other ear eaters in the
$200 price bracket I just don't see any
of that with the $650 price bracket and
the fire phone even if it's $200 on
contract with AT&T there are better
options out there so sorry Amazon
probably should have made an app so I
wasn't able to get my hands on one of
these phones early I'm not that cool I
didn't get to get hands-on but my first
shot at actually playing with this phone
would be pre-ordering one which would
mean paying the $650 with the pre-order
I have that link below and then waiting
a month for to actually come out now
don't get me wrong I love Amazon like I
spend lots of money on Amazon probably
more than any other site on the Internet
I'm an Amazon Prime member most of the
people I know are Amazon Prime members
we all get our textbooks from Amazon but
I won't be buying this phone and neither
should you so that's the Amazon fire
phone explained feel free to share this
video get the word out I've gotten a lot
of questions about this phone so this is
the video for people who are asking
questions so if you know people who are
curious share this video with them
that's been it thanks for watching
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace
you